hi guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about what is
healthier a chicken or pork what do you
think well here's the thing it's kind of
a trick question because when you go buy
chicken commercially from the grocery
store it's highly processed and I never
ever recommend consuming that type of
meat even even you know cow me even any
any of the meats I wouldn't consume that
big why because it's factory farmed
factory farmed is literally disgusting
what occurs in these factories I mean
it's terrible first of all there's GMO
grains soy and corn which you're getting
a lot of pesticides from that that's one
thing right there which leads to all
sorts of health problems there's
antibiotics there is drugs that they
give these animals to grow them that are
arsenic based so you're getting arsenic
it's crazy
you're getting formaldehyde they use
formaldehyde to prevent Salmonella on
pork and chicken in the feed so
formaldehyde is an embalming agent you
know when you die they stick it through
your veins so consuming that isn't crazy
in fact there's even an article recently
that found that like 22 different drugs
in these animals commercially like like
antihistamines and medications and you
know anti like stress drugs all this
stuff that's in this meat it's terrible
so I would never consume anything like
this
okay now let's differentiate over here
what you want to do is you want to get
pasture-raised products preferably from
an online thing or maybe the farmers
market okay sometimes you can find them
in the health of store now that's
becoming more like pasture-raised that
that means that the pig or the chicken
goes out into the grass it actually
consumes grass that's what we want
free-range doesn't really mean anything
means that they could you know walk
around the barn but you need to get past
raise the same same thing with chicken
eggs from a small farmer okay that's the
ideal scene that's what you need to do
because if you saw what happens to this
it'll just make you you know vomit it's
so terrible
they used you want to get non-gmo now
how do you know it's non-gmo well it's
going to have is going to say organic so
if it's organic it's non-gmo that way
you don't get the the grains that are
genetically modified you want no
antibiotics no hormones so when you go
to the store and you at the grocery
store and it says no antibiotics it's
natural that's not what we're doing and
that's not the same that's just one of
the things you're looking for okay no
nitrates if you're buying bacon like no
nitrates nitrates are like a chem
oppressor vut if you want to get no
nitrates you want to get the Paleo bacon
that has like no sugar added so those
are some of the things but this is the
most important pasture raised right here
I'm going to put some links down below
where you can research and find some of
this is it more expensive yes is it
healthier
absolutely it's so healthy but this
stuff here you have to start phasing out
of this because this is very unhealthy
right here so it was a little bit of a
trick question but both of these are bad
unless you're doing this now personally
I prefer more pork now why because it's
fattier it's a fattier meat it's not as
lean now if you have chicken there's
skin on it right I don't think you're
going to do the skin on the pork unless
it's a these pork rinds but the chicken
actually provides some fat the skin so
that would be fine but the pork is
fattier and if you're doing trying to
actually lose weight and do a ketogenic
diet you want more fat in the diet
because the lean meats actually
stimulate insulin more than the fattier
meats so pork would be better on your
insulin levels if you're either
pre-diabetic or insulin resistance than
a chicken but I know people think oh
yeah chicken is really healthy yeah not
quite but if you actually have it
pasture raised it's actually pretty
healthy alright I hope that cleared up
some confusion I'm sure I stir up some
controversy but
it's below thanks for watching